welcome to a Collider heroes interview
special I'm Amy balance of course on row
and we are delighted to welcome Afro
Williams and Andres Ellen from Dark
Phoenix now in theaters we are very
excited to have you come join us and
talk to us a little bit about what it
was like making this movie obviously our
folks will know Anderson Lin from comic
book movie classics like 30 days of
night and nerd classics like a token
verse that you might have heard of and
you're about to fall for Afra Williams
who plays one of the mysterious
characters and if you have not seen the
movie yet run out and see it and then
come back and watch this because we're
gonna have spoilers on the table all
right so with all that out of the way
how's it going you all excited for the
movie congratulations
this is such a big franchise and I would
say along with blade the franchise that
started the superhero movement so it is
is quite impactful for the nerd kind
what was it like the moment you found
out you're a part of something this
important to so many people like how
does that register it was obviously
auditioning for it I had no idea the
character that I was auditioning for you
know we get given different sides and
you know it so very secretive so then to
be on set and kind of get handed
everything and learn everything I'm like
I travelled over with the Australian
stunt team which was led by guy Norris I
was meant to be the just utility stunt
performer also I'm a system fight
coordinator to Richard Norton mmm which
was the fight for NATO on that and yeah
it just escalated from there I said
you're not staying in the chorus line
amazing Jenny and you both play really
important characters to the film and end
to go from auditioning not knowing what
that's going to be into something that's
so impactful like your your fight and
and we're going spoilers like we've
warned you twice your fight with Kurt
Wagner is so cool and I love x-men twos
Nightcrawler moment and I was like how
they gonna possibly make me love a new
nitra oh wait that's how and what was
that fight like on the day fighting
something that actually bamps I know it
was it was really I've never filmed
anything like that before and to kind of
have him BAM scene and then kind of you
know then punch sorry if you haven't
seen it um you know to punch where he
was it was just really interesting to
see how the directors went about
shooting that and all the different
takes because like one scene that would
take you know technically it could take
a couple of minutes to film would take
five hours Wow just to make because it's
like when you reset they're resetting
everything mm-hmm for the scenes in the
Train like that's a lot and if the
carriage is moving it's it's a lot
involved there's a lot that you go
through during that train specifically
what were there any big surprises of
doing that scale of stunt work yep in
the reshoots
I didn't realize because they you know
we went into three months of reshoot so
there's things that the characters doing
now that I wouldn't necessarily have
done in the first in when we showed it
in 2017 so there was a lot that was new
to the table and so exciting the M to
work with the crew and the stunt guys I
very curious about the stunt process COI
has obviously done some of this and been
in that world but for me it's all new
and I love hearing about it what made
this set different or what were some
interesting challenges about this
project coming up with them can you see
the heroes
they wanted I think your was burst of
all five different superheroes but then
they cut it down to two so they had
planks Celine mm-hm
Richard Norton came up with the idea or
of the other beaten so like a
combination of quality mutants but then
it's quite unique and that's the
original character you got to help make
for yourself yes absolutely so we so he
came up the idea about the hair growing
out ten feet and battling and then I
said back in was like okay well how
about we try something so movement you
know and then trying to do something
without something really there yeah it's
quite you know now you know that for
millions of kids like us the ultimate
dream of your life is that someone says
you get to make up your own mutant to
live so thank you for being our avatar
on the big stunts are so tangible and
practical generally you dealing with the
most hands-on literal representation of
filmmaking but on this scale it's the
opposite was that counter to a lot of
your training before this was that like
a new learning curve of like I would
typically have to do this but now this
make-believe hair is doing this like how
did you reframe your stunt work well I
mean being an industry for about 21
years and so like I you know as you know
it flows yeah and with movement and so
just coming up with the idea of this
character was it just flowed really yeah
so once we got all the logistics it
started making sense
were there any particularly inspiring
sources for that movement design or you
want to keep your secrets of your I
think it was just of being able to
manipulate the hair hmm with with
movement of the body you know instead of
just standing there and a hair doing it
mm-hmm you know would seem a lot of that
with whatever yeah I felt like it I'm
not to bring up in humans but unlike
some other properties where the hair
feels like it's an addition this felt
like it was part of you and I really
like them the fighting style felt like
it was like you had multiple limbs
instead of limbs yes and I think that
takes a stunt person who should be given
all the love and credit because some
people they move so differently and I
think it's really important that
Hollywood sees that these movies can't
exist without people that move for a
living so it was beautiful to see that
translate it was amazing speaking of the
people without whom the movie wouldn't
exist there anything you have to like
any experiences that you took away from
this cast that you work with and the
team that was with you on this it was an
amazing cast I will say just speaking of
the stunts when I had my my stunt scenes
the stunt team was so amazing it was
literally a group that would come with
me they're like okay so this is how you
can move this snake and do this when I
had to get rigged up to get shot at they
were like this is how you're gonna do it
and I'm like this stunt and the crew
were amazing and the actors everyone
it's I mean it's a well-oiled rig I
think it's been going for a long time so
everyone works so well together it was a
pleasure working with Jessica Chastain
to be part of her little group she's an
absolute sweetheart and incredibly
talented and I just I think everyone
just works so well together that was the
biggest thing I took away I was like for
such a huge production how smooth
everything goes you know how it's just
like everyone has so much respect for
each other it was it was a very
incredible job to be a part of here yeah
it's a very unique thing and I think in
this case very positively that you come
back to a film and get to like recreate
some things and what was it like from a
performer standpoint to like have not
seen these folks and then come back and
felt like the well-oiled machine you
felt back into the wells machine how is
it different between the time apart well
as an actor you know you're always when
you have to say goodbye to a character
there's always that
and then to be able to come back for
another three months
[Laughter]
reborn from the ashes you're exactly and
then you have that opportunity to really
develop deeper relationships with your
co-workers to get to explore that
character deeper have more time on that
I spent I think that was it was it was a
gift
absolutely yeah I was so impressed with
their there are some moments where you
have to convey a ton of information in
like three lines of dialogue and very
few can do that like Michael Fassbender
Batman when he like just says in me like
I believe every day you have to be like
that he was right no horrible the scene
where you're introduced I was completely
on board having known nothing of the
things he did to absolve himself like
he's been a criminal and all of a sudden
like he's leaving what a guy what was
life like in that like community was
there was their backstory discussed with
like Michael Fassbender with Simon was
there were there like a unity it felt so
[Laughter]
[Music]
cuz you helped create that character and
just stood into it I feel like you
already you didn't really have to
prepare so much because like the look
the whoever was doing the production
design for that like gave the whole
thing a very established look that helps
the audience fill in all the pieces
there so it's need to know that everyone
was just like we have what we need we
have what we need to communicate that no
Nightcrawler specifically is so specific
looking and and so iconic to the world
of x-men the first time you saw
Nightcrawler and who that was going to
be costume what was the moment of
because not the average person will
never get to see how cool that looks
in life unlike the tale I was just like
looking at him and because he's
Australian as well and we have quite a
few scenes together it was really fun to
work on x-men with a fellow Australian
and have those fight scenes and really
he's it he's a sweetheart
yes yeah but I just oh you got a hole in
your pants you chew individually how did
you first get into stunt work what was
the what drew you to it like what led
you down that path I mean this is I'm an
actor I'm not I haven't done stunts
before so this was really it was an
eye-opener but I had an amazing team to
work with me and Jim churchmen the stunt
coordinator on x-men was also incredibly
helpful
I just really experienced people bring
it to anybody okay very professional
very safe great but I've actually walked
away and I'm like I want to do more for
you when did you know you wanted to do
more I I was a hairdresser it all makes
sense and I I was doing some extra work
on Xena and Hercules way back then thank
you yeah and I saw these stunt
performers get up and do their thing and
so hard I'd really love to do that
because I was doing martial arts at the
time cool and then you know like how you
put it out there and then all of a
sudden the road just led me to down the
path where I'm all of a sudden the
instructor that I was training with he
knew the stunt coordinator
that was trying to put a team together
to go down to Lord of the Rings it's a
lot of the stunt performers were yeah so
then got him there was only only about
ten of us that went down to Wellington
to begin with that's so cool just went
from there
you watched that whole world grow cuz
you've stayed involved with the Tolkien
verse it was it was amazing it was
amazing journey got to travel in New
Zealand to start a journey with the
hobbits on a journey yeah and then going
from one of the most lush and visually
like colorful universes to 30 days of
night which is as bleak as it gets and
now you're balancing it with x-men you
know the yin and yang what would you
like to do that you haven't gotten to do
yet so much to do right and you know
what whatever it is I'll enjoy doing it
[Laughter]
perspective was there any moment on set
you'd like to share like a favorite day
any crazy high drinks like what was that
like when you think back on the time on
set like what's a fond memory that you
guys have from any specific day or funny
I feel like every day was a ride I mean
there long days right you're on set for
16 18 hour days I feel like my highlight
was getting raped with like 60 blanks
and getting what I call the squibs yes
yeah yeah it was hurt nice 30 on each
side and what I'm getting shot at kind
of you know
[Applause]
I was also scared I'm like he's gonna
hurt like these glass things but then
you get and you're like oh no I got this
squib deck - good day hander any fix yo
yeah the whole creation of of everything
really loved the character and that was
my favorite and then when when we had
something together we showed the second
unit director and then he was like okay
which is a guy Norris and then he was
like okay so let's go and show Simon you
know and then showed Simon and he really
liked him then it was like the next
question was who's gonna play this guy
and then it came back to me that I was
gonna be playing Lotus okay
so then yeah the journey began from
there is just amazing that's wonderful I
hope it like quake from agents of shield
we see Red Lotus in the comics I hope it
translates like I love when we see
mediums go yeah really cool is there
anything before the movie well the
movies out when people are watching it
right now because it is we've been
spoiler all these things but is there
anything you want people to take away
from the x-men like the x-men's message
to me is so important and so rad is
there anything from set you guys want
the people to know I always end with a
tricky question so you know yeah I feel
like just be yourself I think that's a
great message to take away from that but
everyone is different we all have quirks
we all have our talents people are
always gonna judge us but make sure you
say to yourself I think that is
important thing to take away from all
these x-men that's yeah I can't top that
that's thank you so much for joining us
absolutely this long road is out there
the movie is finally out your your lives
of secrecy can can finally end is that
kind of are you looking forward to that
finally getting to share this with
people it's been like it's almost been a
two-year it's it's a long time
absolutely but I will just say working
with Simon he it was amazing to work
with the director who's written the
script you know so much about the
characters yeah and to work with him he
was he was an absolute sweetheart I'll
also say his directing like a Jim Lee
comic is so important there were frames
that were literally from x-men 92 and
that made me so happy so as a nerd I was
really excited fighting that looked like
when I thought well folks check out
x-men it is in theaters right now and
thank you guys so much where can they
find you on the Internet where can I cut
you down are your eye on Twitter's
answer in stores ephra underscore J
we've been a on the end fantastic
are you into running Internet's and
being perfect
hug them down they did incredible work
thank you guys so much for joining us
having us guys appreciate it and
congratulations thank you so until next
week stay sweaty thanks guys